[Music]
when steve jobs died in 2011 his
admirers paid tribute around the world
this kind of turnout was usually
reserved for rock stars not a ceo
yet this age arguably belongs to those
who build the future
according to the forbes list of the
richest people in the world in 2021
seven out of the top ten made their
fortune in engineering
amazon's jeff bezos tesla and spacex's
elon musk
microsoft's bill gates facebook's mark
zuckerberg
oracle's larry ellison google's larry
page and sergey brin
it's hard to think of an engineer from
the 70s who was super well known
yet today's engineers are household
names whether we love him or
love to hate him musk even guest-hosted
saturday night live which is usually
reserved for famous actors and artists
he's a new kind of celebrity with such a
huge twitter following
that he's a walking advertisement for
tesla in fact
tesla doesn't spend money on advertising
which i talked about in another video
so how did engineers become cool
they used to be known for building
public infrastructure like bridges and
dams
necessary for any functioning society
but not something that would normally
attract crowds
then jobs came along he didn't have a
technical background but he had his
hands in everything at apple
including engineering the world changed
when he put the internet in everyone's
pocket with the introduction of the
iphone in 2007
the late apple ceo built a following by
creating personal
inventions that excited people since
then engineers have continued to create
products that are in your personal space
be it a smart watch or social media
which has in turn
made them famous and the appetite for
such products is only growing
engineers are expected to experience a
three percent job growth in a decade
which is on par with average
while the demand for software developers
is predicted to soar
22 they're the ones responsible for
writing and designing code to develop
apps in other words creating the
products we crave
an increasing number of people are
choosing the profession in india
30 of students pursued a degree in stem
science technology engineering and
mathematics which produced almost 2.7
million graduates in 2018. where i live
in canada
enrollment in math computer and
information sciences has increased
47 comparing a recent academic year to
an earlier one
in a previous video i mentioned that
engineering degrees are now more common
than mba degrees amongst the world's top
performing
ceos which makes sense given some of the
biggest companies are tech giants
there's also the belief that engineers
rise to the top because they're good
problem solvers
google's former chief financial officer
patrick pichette once pointed out that
google is really an engineering company
with all these computer scientists that
see the world as a completely broken
place
engineers try to solve the most pressing
issues of the day using technology
musk is a self-taught engineer who wants
to reduce pollution with his electric
vehicles
and is confident the century-long
dominance of the internal combustion
engine
otherwise known as ice is coming to a
close well i don't think there will be
at ice industry long term
there's still like some steam engines
made somewhere but like they're just
basically
sort of quirky collector's items i mean
that will be the future of the internal
combustion engine car
at the same time people like him have
warned of a dark side to technology
he believes super intelligent machines
could pose a threat to humanity
and has called for government oversight
of artificial intelligence
fearing ai will surpass humans and
intelligence in the way we outsmart
cats smart machines are expected to
eliminate many human jobs
fedex has now teamed up with a robotics
company to test out autonomous delivery
vehicles
amazon runs cashier-less grocery stores
and wants to deliver packages by drone
in under 30 minutes
the world economic forum says the rise
of automation will result in a loss of
85 million jobs by 2025
yet in the same breath adds 97 million
new jobs will be created
such as ai and machine learning
specialists and data analysts
there's also the argument that future
technology will redefine the meaning of
the traditional work
week more than a hundred years ago
people worked 70 hours a week
on average with the industrial
revolution and labor laws it's now down
to about 35 hours
the former head of british petroleum
laura john brown remarked
why do we then define work as a 35 hour
a week why can't it be 17 and a half
behind these forces of societal change
are engineers
who dream big bezos space venture blue
origin has dreamt up space colonies
straight out of 70s science fiction
though the plan hasn't won over a fellow
billionaire who has a different vision
of humanity
in space musk spacex expects mars to be
colonized by a constant flow of humans
traveling aboard starships
so long as we have a desire for new
adventures and new things
engineers will continue to build the
future and enjoy all the attention that
comes along with it
at the core of an engineer is
exceptional skill and ability
if you'd like to brush up on your math
or computer science skills or you simply
want to learn more about how our world
works my sponsor brilliant can help
and it's free to sign up brilliant is a
website and app built off the principle
of learning while doing
you simply pick a course and jump right
in one of my favorites is the logic
courses
if you're feeling stuck on a problem you
can read the explanations to find out
more
brilliant has something for everybody
besides the math science and computer
science courses
you can even dive into cutting edge
topics like cryptocurrency
if you'd like to join me and a community
of 8 million learners and educators
click the link in my description
or visit brilliant.org newsthink the
first 200 people to use my link will get
20
off the premium subscription which gives
you unlimited access to all the courses
for newstank i'm cindy palm